hey guys first of all thank you for
clicking you're about to watch a new
video or another video on YouTube and
before you do - 1 2 9 3 1 5 7 3 1 what
I'm doing in my text community is
bonkers it's instant it's access it's
exclusive and now enjoy this YouTube
videos Gary B and my number one advice
to Millennials in the way that you asked
it is
you got your prospective
[Music]
[Music]
log I'm in San Francisco in a couple
hours I'll be in Portland for a big
meeting and fun kind of talk here with
Microsoft a fireside chat so may lead me
into some new places so I'm sure d-roc
and I are both optimistic that I might
talk about something new because when
you have 12 15 23 foundational beliefs
the only way you get new stuff is QA or
when new platforms emerge like tic toc
or when new cultural things happen like
slime or Linkedin becomes organic reach
so I'm a byproduct of a changing
behavior graph with 23 things I believe
in I'm not gonna use 23 22 cuz [ __ ]
Michael Jordan
[Music]
there's nothing more important than not
allowing your parents to have any
leverage I mean it
parents give money because they want
control so my number one advice to
Millennials in the way that you asked it
is to not rely on parents and then
number two took one to buy time we
actually have our whole lives backwards
you should be doing the most high-risk
high-reward work from 20 to 30 the
problem is that's when everybody expects
you to grow up I think and grow up has
transferred in on modern society to save
I mean I think that everybody under 30
should be tasting everything to get a
better sense of what they're interested
in so I'd like you to call your parents
and tell them if they are or they may
not be I don't want any more money from
you and then I want you and then and
then I want you to go on a plane and go
to Scotland for no reason
listen I get tens of thousands of DMS
from kids that are in their 20s and 30s
that have deep underlining resentment
and depression because their parents are
quietly paying for their lives which I
then tell them like don't take the money
jerk but there's nothing there's almost
nothing worse than a parent subsidizing
secretly their child's grown-up life it
leads it will eventually be exposed and
talked about and I can't wait because a
lot of the underlining depression that
is confusing people is actually coming
from those sources and it's even scarier
when you dig underneath it because what
you start realizing is parents want to
posture in front of their friends that
little Sallie and Johnny are doing well
and that's why they're riding a BMW or
have a business when quietly they're the
ones paying for it if you don't stand on
your own two feet and you're a grown-up
me sad Thanks as a father of three girls
yes
by creating fake environments
it's like accountability is the
framework of happiness and that is just
not the current belief of parenting hey
guys sorry to interrupt your video I'm
just giving you this call for my number
to let you know that you have to join my
text community to one two nine three one
five seven three one hit me up with a
text give them social media no a hundred
percent really 100 percent kidding me of
course stop them because because that's
it that's right that's it inevitable if
they're unable to do give them the tools
emotionally to deal with judgment not
keep them away from tick-tock got it
quantifying giving them the ability to
quantify feedback and the way kids get
confidence is actually by doing things
on their own merit not by the
subsidization of their parents of them
diseases other percent like it's a very
big deal brother like like use a quarter
girls age of 1200 yeah and like and they
have extra dynamics of judgment from a
physical standpoint things of that
nature but it's gonna come down to there
when you pay and and create fake you
know feedback it just leads to
entitlement which creates vulnerability
and fear
yeah you're lucky that it's so early
it's so early all right father to father
I've got two kids a teenage to a 15 year
old daughter dirty old son my son might
not make it to 14 but that's a different
story
so my doubt you a lot of what you preach
is about like not giving a [ __ ] about
what other people think right
my daughter is really [ __ ] good at
that that's awesome
no because she becomes condescending no
delusional wow that's a great it's not
that she doesn't care but there's no
there's no empathy or kindness behind it
so she doesn't have compassion yes okay
did everybody anybody yeah
has she started feeling the
ramifications socially too that she
doesn't care that's the problem for now
no doubt and so I think look I think
it's a very fine line look radical
candor around love and she's not going
to she's 15 yeah but being consistent on
delivering it not out of frustration but
just a constant tone is what you want to
know that's I'm at frustration because I
can see the mistake she's making right I
see the friends leaving her die on your
own sword
meaning communicated with empathy honey
over vinegar is always the delivery
mechanism of information that matters my
wife and I are trying to figure out the
balance of honey on a dagger
yeah and sometimes parents divide and
conquer my recommendation and I'm
starting to do it already I'm starting
to get into it with my kids 10 and 7 as
well I believe that it's a very
challenging as we love them
don't go with the hunt here's the story
honey
you notice how Kelly doesn't hang out
with you anymore it's because you
weren't compassionate to her and one day
you know it's a whole one day you're
gonna really like there's gonna be a
problem instead of going with that
that's me right now right that's
whatever that's why I'm good I know
that's where you are that's where
everyone goes I think you go with like
honey you do you you know you I'm
observing and I'm actually wildly
neutral on this even though I'm your dad
cuz I love doing this is what's
happening
I know that you know you they're not
going to admit it to me now because
you're my daughter I know you know if
there's any way I can help in tweaking
it
or if you ever want my outside
observation which you don't want now let
me know that's a great way of saying it
but now you're delivering it in a way
where you're talking even not down and
nobody likes being talked down to
especially kids and that's a really good
open opportunity for her to come in and
you leave it yeah yeah and when I
deliver that which I will and I've done
it for executives best friends and
eventually I'll do it with my kids I
don't need the Molina net you can see
what I did there I bring the framework
for them to lean in the third time it
happens and now they're frustrated and
then I [ __ ] I better go to dad cuz he
set up that opening cuz right now you're
scolding down you see and we try hard
and I believe you I can tell it's funny
even if they're not scolding it's still
going this way absolutely and I think
the way to win 15 year old
what's-her-name Ava 15 or old Ava wants
it if you go this way there's a switch
that happens that gives you a shot Ava
promise me one thing
don't listen to dad you know what you're
doing but kindness always wins in the
end
[Music]
Dallas awesome and so one thing I've
heard you touched on a lot and when come
into depth into with jay Shetty yes was
having no expectations and that will
help you be more grateful yes preciate
it yes I think my personal life I've
seen that yes how do we translate that
into the workplace where we are so
interdependent on other people that's a
really good point so you know where that
has bit me in the ass is not holding
people accountable on merit which has
been an evolution because I'm truly back
to what I said earlier about like
employees should if they own the same
amount I probably took it too far and
when I correct it I'm always better I
think look I think where it gets tricky
is when you're dependent on a partner
and then you're being affected by it by
a boss who she or he may not have all
the context one becomes frustrated I
think it just becomes this is one big
game of communication and then being at
the mercy of the company like everybody
here is at the mercy of the company and
you need to understand that like you
know and that's okay but the way you do
it is you either have the courage to
have a fruitful but kandra's
conversation with the person that's
letting you down with the people above
you what most people do it's amazing to
me i watch people who hadn't been in my
company for seven years I have a real
relationship with but they would rather
you know vent on slack or in the boys
bathroom then come and talk to me for
five minutes to address it people really
enjoy complaining because a lot of
people actually are fascinated you know
people really enjoy the crutch of having
something to blame that's the best part
of being an employee like what sucks
about entrepreneurship is it's your
fault every single problem at
vaynermedia is 100% my fault
I've empowered the people or I myself
I'm doing it the best part of all of you
sitting here is you can blame someone
it's [ __ ] fun you know like it's why
we love having parents you blame them
[ __ ] up [ __ ] you know so I think it's
about communication and then you're at
the you know one of the reasons I think
veiners had success at its end I'm
genuinely not short-term financially
motivated and I genuinely view myself as
the logo and I don't care if somebody's
been with me for ten years or one day as
a matter of fact I would argue that
every time there's a beef between
somebody senior and somebody underneath
I be fought subconsciously to believe in
the person underneath because I believe
the person above has more to lose it's
not always true
obviously I've gone millions of times in
both ways but a lot of companies just
are top-down organization thank you so
much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]